[Narrator] So, what I would like you to do next is to modify our algorithm
to take the lists of particles and importance weights
to sample N times with replacement and new particles
with a sampling probability proportional to the importance weights,
or in the code now that we calculated our new particles
and the corresponding importance weights, construct a new particle set P3,
which we will call P, again, when everything is said and done,
so that the particles in P3 are drawn from P according to the importance weights W.
Now to warn you this is more difficult than it looks like.
I'm going to show you a trick in a second, so if you fail to do this don't worry.
I give you a chance to do it right now, but then I'm going to tell you
a little bit more about how to organize this
in an efficient way and you get a second chance.
So, try it out, see if you can do it, and if you fail
look for my advice and then try it again.